foreign
Alex is in Seattle hey Alex what's up
hey Dave and Ken so I made a kind of a
silly mistake when I was a little
younger back in you're the only one
I know right everyone else has it right
[Laughter]
nobody makes mistakes silly mistakes
when they're young that never happens
okay so what'd you do man
so I bought a house
um I bought a house with a mortgage
um got really low interest rate however
instead of refinancing a few years later
I went to my folks and asked if they
would pay it off and I could just pay
them at zero percent I'm realizing that
was now very silly um now that I'm
following your program
um especially it's affecting my
relationship with them and some of my
other family members so I'm trying to
figure out what the best decision is to
kind of pull out of that
um and like maybe do something like
underwriting with like Churchill I
started talking to them about that the
concern is because I haven't had a like
a payment or a mortgage for so long now
that I'm not going to be able to do
underwriting so I'm trying to figure out
what the best way is to get a regular
mortgage again
okay Churchill Mortgage can help you do
manual underwriting that does not
require a credit score
right you don't have to have to
establish that you pay your utilities on
time and you can prove that you pay your
parents timely with simply your checking
account history can't you
yes okay that that's the conversation we
had so far yeah so you can prove you
paid the payments and you prove you pay
your light bill you prove you pay your
water bill you can prove your income
I assume what's your what's your income
uh 105. okay got a great income how old
are you
uh 27 what's the house worth
it's currently worth 600 and what do you
owe on it
uh 296.
okay so 50 mortgage should not be a
reach
correct it's not a big deal tons and
tons of equity
you've got a great income how long have
you been in this job
uh five years yeah stable good income
and you pay you can show that you paid
your parents Timely
right
yes I can should be a no-brainer for a
manual underwriting and if the person
you're talking to a Churchill Mortgage
can't figure that out ask to speak to
their boss because Churchill Mortgage
specializes in this in manual
underwriting because we teach people to
do it all the time and we send them a
lot of business because they're a
sponsor for 25 years and they'll take
good care of you somebody there will for
sure
um so get on the phone with them and
they'll walk you through this we do it
all the time I mean it's not it's not
this is not a problem so what's the
strain with the other family members
what are they talked about
uh I have a few family members that are
happy with you of course but I ignore
those
um the other one I didn't I didn't get a
mortgage with your parents why are they
not happy with you for having a mortgage
no unhappy with Dave Ramsey that but I
ignore them
Oh I thought you said your parents and
your other family members weren't happy
with you is putting a strain on your
relationships
oh sorry
uh I've had other family members ask my
parents for money
so I am feeling the stress of I was
permitted yes and they were permitted no
well that's not your fault
agreed but they're mad at you
no they don't know about it that's the
the bigger thing okay all right and you
is there a stress with your parents
there wasn't at first they always give
me advice however it feels like the
advice is now more the money talking
sometimes okay
yeah the borrower is slave to the lender
and um indeed you know and there's
people in every family that don't like
Dave Ramsey including Dave Ramsey's
family what say it's not so
it's uh it's something I've come to live
with Ken yes you're doing you're doing
well you're doing well with it it's
working out for me yeah if you only piss
off half of America you can still make a
really good living
and help a whole lot of people and uh
you know what we end up with is
um you know people that didn't want to
be helped uh and that's that's the
problem I want to make sure people don't
miss this Dave because we've taught this
for a long long time but this is a a
family who the parents wanted to help
this young man out they did and even
though they wanted to it still changes
the dynamic what is it about this that
we that why we create this boundary why
we preach this boundary
well it is a spiritual law
the borrower is slave to the lender
and the Bible doesn't say except in
cases where it's your mother and father
right now it doesn't say that or
accepting cases where Everyone likes
every no don't say that it says 100 of
the time that you borrow money
you take the position spiritually
mathematically
relationally of slave now you might have
a very kind and gentle master
that is very classy
um when we went broke uh 30 plus years
ago uh Sharon's dad loaned us some money
to keep a car
and he's the kindest most saintly man
gentle quite the opposite of Sharon's
husband and um you know and he he
um you know we worked our way through
got it paid off and he he never one time
made us feel uncomfortable by his
actions or his attitudes but I can tell
you sitting at Thanksgiving dinner felt
different yes until I got that cleared
that's good because it's in the air you
can't change it you can't fix it and uh
did it make me more uncomfortable than
it did Sharon because it was her dad
yeah yeah I did of course but it doesn't
but you know it doesn't matter it's a
slave master relationship you change it
so when you loan your friend money they
are no longer your friend
you can't keep that from happening
they're your friend is a secondary thing
their primary relationship is now slave
and master yeah and it changes the
dynamic it changes the spirit in the air
you can smell it when you walk into
Thanksgiving dinner and you can submit
you can feel it and Mom and Dad in this
case are probably pretty cool people uh
they're just trying to help again but
now they feel the real need to help
that's right and now they've gone over
the helpline and gone into the
controlling line and now they're
starting to interfere that's correct and
uh they don't really have the right to
do that except that they are owed 300
296 thousand dollars which kind of
changes the it does changes your vocal
cords just a little bit when you say it
out loud this is 300 not 3096 thousand
dollars yeah and you're going on
vacation what right you know it's just
like you they may be uh pressuring him
on uh professional moves yeah you know
and and this is right maturity that girl
you're dating spends a lot that's right
you can get real control that's true I
mean you can get all into crap when you
don't have the right to but you changed
the relationship so you know the old
joke is if you loan your brother-in-law
a hundred dollars and he never speaks to
you again was it worth it